computed tomography scan or CT scan uses
computers and rotating x-ray machines to
create cross-sectional images of the
body
these images provide more detailed
information than typical x-ray images
in this video we will learn how we do CT
scan mechanisms of CT scan
use of CT scan and interpretation of CT
scan data this video is made in
collaboration with the nordmatic
why we need CT scan when we have x-ray
now x-ray also gives you an image of the
body a radiological image CDs can also
gives you an radiological image but the
image is of higher resolution and that
is why we need CT scan over x-ray
now how we perform a CT scan now CT scan
machine or the Gantry is placed in a
separate room the patient is made to lie
on a stretcher near the Gantry then the
patient inserts within the Gantry and
the operator sits in a separate room
where on a computer the operator can see
the generated image
and the Gantry and the patient is kept
in a radiation proof room where the
glass and the walls are made up of lead
which protects the operator from
radiation
now the Gantry has sensors all over its
body and has extra tubes now this extra
tubes fire x-rays towards the body and
the sensors pick up and form an image
now in this manner the extra tube
rotates and again gives another
projection then again rotates gives
another projection and this is how
multiple projections are the same slice
of the body is taken and now these
multiple projections are processed using
a computer software and finally they
overlap to generate one single high
resolution image
now when we look at a CD scan we look at
a CD scan from the bottom end of a
patient
and hence the CD scan appear somewhat
like this now in this image even though
the lever appears on the left hand side
it is the right hand side of the patient
and the spleen even though it appears to
be on the right hand side it is the
patient's left hand side because this is
the typical way of looking at a CD scan
that is from the foot end of the patient
now with this knowledge let us
understand what are the types of CT scan
now CT scan can be a non-contrast CT
scan a contrast enhanced CD scan where
you can clearly make out the vasculature
of the different anatomical structures
and finally we have something known as a
3D CT scan or three-dimensional CT scan
where the computer software is a
recreate a three-dimensional image of
the body based on the projections that
we take in the CD scan machine
now let us interpret the CD scan data
now on the left hand side we have an
x-ray on the right hand side we have a
CT scan in the x-rays we can see bones
mainly even though we get to see other
soft tissues but the resolution is very
poor we get to see bones in the CD scan
as well but apart from that we also get
to see vessels and soft tissue clearly
and hence we require a CT scan so in
summary we can say that CT scan
technique reviews The anatomical picture
of your tissues and organs with better
resolution in this technique the X-ray
play X-Ray is the key player mechanism
of the CD scan we have already discussed
and use of CT scan also
now and we also learned how to interpret
a CT scan data now for high quality
notes and flashcards follow animated
biology with Urban on Instagram and
Facebook now you can also support our
Channel through patreon or through super
thanks so that we can continue to make
high quality educational content for
free the super thanks button will be in
the bottom right corner of any video you
can contribute using paytm PayPal or UPI
now if you wish to connect with arpan
the connection links will be given in
the description box below for medicine
related content follow the nerd medic
YouTube channel and please hit the like
button share this video and your peers
and if you haven't subscribed to the
Channel please hit the Subscribe button
so that you never miss an update from
this channel until then bye bye see you
in the next one